hallo leute und herzlich willkommen
zurück bei einer neuen folge kari
antwortet ich beantworte heute wieder
eure fragen zu easy german zur deutschen
sprache und zur deutschen kultur hans
bauer schreibt machbar eine easy german
episode in der die leute fragt was sie
zur aktuellen flüchtlings debatte denken
kannst das hast du vor zwei wochen durch
geschrieben und wir haben das ja am
sonntag schon gemacht
eine episode gemacht zum thema
flüchtlinge in deutschland ist gab viele
sehr gute kommentare dazu allerdings
muss man sagen das ist leider auch
negative kommentare gehabt und es gab
viele dislike dieses video hatte in
einem tag mehr dislike als alle anderen
videos nach einem jahr was natürlich
etwas traurig ist aber auch nicht sehr
überraschend denn dieses thema
polarisiert gerade sehr und es gibt
viele leute die im netz unterwegs sind
und versuchen ihre negativen kommentare
rassistische stimmung in allen möglichen
formen zum ausdruck zu bringen
ja kurz zum hintergrund des videos wir
waren in hannover dort waren wir
eingeladen von der stiftung
partnerschaft mit afrika an einem
workshop teilzunehmen und dort hat es
sich einfach ergeben dass wir diese
frage gestellt haben
einige leute haben uns schon gefragt ist
das wirklich ausgewogen sind dass alle
meinungen wir können sagen in diesem
fall waren es alle
nun allerdings muss man natürlich dazu
sagen dass wir auf einem fest der
kulturen waren das heißt dort sind sehr
viele leute die sowieso sehr offen sind
gegenüber anderen kulturen und man muss
auch sagen wir haben nicht so viele
leute gefragt denn es hat angefangen zu
regnen und wir hatten nur sehr kurz zeit
aber alle kommentare die im video seht
sind tatsächlich die antworten die wir
bekommen haben und da war viele positive
bei
manche leute sagen wo sind denn die
negativen fragen zum beispiel fraktion
was sagen die leute eigentlich die gegen
die aufnahme von flüchtlingen sind und
micron elmar grund schreibt it my way to
the way german people received the
fugees germany and girls ein exempel
world lieblingsvideo maine positiv
kommentar zur like to know about the
other side of the boy like to hear worte
negativseite in der economy zu zeiten
zur seite et cetera auf receiving
graffitis in deutschland neues video
jetzt habe ich insgesamt vier
anmerkungen jetzt um euch ein bisschen
zu erklären warum die leute im video so
positiv geantwortet haben denn das ist
nicht eine ausnahmeerscheinung in
deutschland gibt es gerade sehr viele
leute die das unterstützen und auch die
regierungspolitik unterstützen um die
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
natürlich gibt es auch leute die dagegen
sind also hier dazu vier kurze
anmerkungen von mir als erstes hast du
fragt nach den ökonomischen nachteilen
natürlich gibt es das in vielen ländern
dass menschen angst haben wenn sehr
viele leute in ein land kommt hat man
angst dass diese leute die einwandern
die immigranten vielleicht arbeitsplätze
wegnehmen dass es schwieriger wird für
leute dass es sich ökonomisch de
stabilisiert gleichzeitig muss man
wissen dass in deutschland diese angst
im moment nicht sehr stark ist in
deutschland
ein wirtschaftlich starkes land
gegensatz zu vielen anderen ländern in
europa haben wir von der finanzkrise
also wir persönlich fast gar nichts
gemerkt es gibt eine sehr relativ
niedrige arbeitslosenquote und den
meisten deutschen geht es echt gut das
heißt wir haben auch ein bisschen das
gefühl dass wir helfen können und wir
was positives machen können die zweite
frage haben zur sozialen integration und
zu kulturellen hintergrund da gibt es
tatsächlich vielleicht kann man sagen
ein paar mehr befürchtungen in
deutschland denn natürlich gibt es in
aller welt sehr unterschiedliche
wertesysteme und man muss dazu sagen
dass viele leute auch angst haben in
deutschland das ist vielleicht zu
problemen kommen könnte zwischen den
kulturen es gibt viele leute die ein
wandern viele leute die aus
hintergründen einwandern die andere
kulturelle werte haben und die auch
manchmal probleme mitbringen
nicht umsonst fliehen viele menschen
denn wenn in diesen ländern alles gut
wäre würden sie wahrscheinlich ihre
heimat nicht freiwillig verlassen und so
haben natürlich auch viele deutsche
angst dass vielleicht die leute die
hinkommen ihre probleme mitbringen aber
und jetzt kommt der dritte punkt ein
großes aber dazu man muss natürlich
wissen dass in deutschland schon sehr
viele leute eingewandert sind in den
60er und 70er jahren gab es viele
gastarbeiter die deutschland eingeladen
hat als deutschland nämlich mehr
arbeitskräfte brauchte als in
deutschland hatten und diese leute kamen
auch großteils aus muslimischen ländern
vor allem aus der türkei und leben auch
vielfach heute noch bei uns in
deutschland gibt es vier millionen
muslime und das führt auch dazu dass die
deutschen viel weniger angst haben vor
uns lieben als es vielleicht andere
da haben denn tatsächlich ist es so die
leute die schon zusammen leben und wo es
eigentlich großteil sehr gut läuft
da muss man keine ängste haben und da
muss man hat man einfach nicht so viel
angst das kann man auch statistisch
sehen in europa die angst vor fremden
die angst vor in diesem fall vor dem
islam ist gerade in den europäischen
ländern stark und auch in den regionen
stark wo es sehr wenig muslime gibt was
an erstmal ein bisschen komisch vorkommt
im endeffekt geht es darum vorurteile
kann man abbauen durch wissen und wissen
kann man nur bekommen wenn man eben
zusammen lebt und sich kennenlernt und
das möchten wir auch mit unserem
programm machen
so jetzt kommen wir zum vierten punkt
viele von euch haben uns vorgeworfen in
den kommentaren dass wir in unserem
video nicht die wahrheit sagen aber
bringen diesmal auf den punkt die
wahrheit ist wir sind erstens rechtlich
dazu verpflichtet menschen aufzunehmen
denen in ihren heimatländern die
lebensgrundlage entzogen wurde das steht
in unserem grundgesetz und so machen wir
es natürlich auch denn wir müssen den
leuten die zu uns kommen und die
politisch verfolgt sind vom krieg
bedroht sind auch die möglichkeit geben
hier zu bleiben
das zweite ist wir sind nicht nur
rechtlich dazu verpflichtet sondern auch
moralisch viele von euch lachen oft
darüber dass wir deutschen heutzutage
noch so eng mit unserer vergangenheit
verbunden sind auch in euren kommentaren
lese ich das immer wieder warum denkt
ihr deutschen noch an den zweiten
weltkrieg und so weiter seid doch mal
stolz auf unser land aber ihr müsst doch
einfach verstehen wie ist das eigentlich
in einem land aufzuwachsen das vor
wenigen jahrzehnten noch die ganze welt
in ein unfassbares leid gestürzt hat wir
deutschen können und wollen
nicht vergessen was damals passiert ist
das was da alles passiert es war eine
grosse schande und das empfinden wir
auch heute noch so ich zum beispiel bin
31 jahre 1
natürlich bin ich persönlich nicht dafür
verantwortlich was im zweiten weltkrieg
passiert ist aber ich will mit dafür
verantwortlich dass so etwas nie wieder
passiert und ganz ehrlich wenn ich
heutzutage sehe dass deutsche in meinem
alter zu asylunterkünften gehen und
diese angst denken und das ist nicht ein
einzelfall das ist in diesem jahr schon
60 mal passiert dann ist das einfach
eine gigantische schande für mich und
ich denke dass das viele leute in meiner
generation auch so empfinden und gerade
deshalb wollen wir etwas tun damit wir
das nicht als einzige tat stehen lassen
damit das nicht alleine steht wir
möchten nicht dass wir die medien jeden
tag diese bilder sehen wie menschen in
deutschland nicht willkommen sind viele
menschen in deutschland leiden
in einem land wo sie eigentlich schutz
bekommen sollten und deswegen tun wir
was wir tun können was wir mit unseren
benützen können ist videos drehen
darin sind wir gut das mögen wir gerne
und wir möchten mit diesen videos auch
dafür sorgen dass sich kulturen
austauschen
darauf freuen wir uns und wir hoffen
auch dass er dabei mitmacht ja das ist
jetzt ein sehr ernstes thema aber das
muss auch mal sein einer von euch hat
tatsächlich heute geschrieben wir sollen
doch nicht so viel politische themen
machen will sondern mehr machen
beides gehört dazu wir machen weiß ihr
wisst nächste woche zum beispiel gibt es
eine neue koch episode bei klaus auch
das ist teil unserer kultur und dessen
was wir zeigen wollen genauso ist es
aber politik und auch ernstere themen
und wir möchten gerne unserem programm
immer beides menschen hier schon wieder
eine politische frage
thomas apel schreibt vielleicht ist es
für die anderen uninteressant aber ich
würde gerne mal wissen
neuer gesundheitssystem funktioniert
zahlen alle monatlich an den start kann
man selber aussuchen wo man sich
behandeln lässt
in europa ist es bei jedem land anders
und ich weiß nicht ob die deutschen
zufrieden sind mit ihrem system kriegen
die einwanderer bzw
neuankömmlinge ärztliche hilfe thomas da
könnte ich natürlich jetzt einen ganzen
vortrag zu halten weil das
gesundheitssystem bei uns ist sehr
komplex aber um es kurz zusammenzufassen
deutschland ist ein sozialstaat kann man
sagen und deswegen ist das
gesundheitssystem bei uns auch teil des
der staatlichen regelung und ist sogar
verpflichtend das heißt jeder
deutschland eine krankenversicherung zu
deiner frage auch neuankömmlinge auch
leute die noch in asyl bewerbungsprozess
sind bekommen ärztliche hilfe
und so ist es auch bei uns wenn wir zum
beispiel angestellt sind
dann ist unser arbeitgeber sogar
verpflichtet einen teil unserer karten
versicherung zu zahlen
und wir der arbeitnehmer zahlen den
anderen teil
und so muss jeder deutsche immer einen
gewissen prozentsatz des einkommens auch
dann wenn er selbstständig ist an die
krankenkassen zahlen und dafür bekommen
sie gesundheitsleistungen umsonst kann
man sich selber aussuchen wo man
behandelt wird in der regel schon
tatsächlich kann man sich selber ernst
aussuchen und das funktioniert noch ganz
gut sind die deutschen mit dem
gesundheitssystem zufrieden das ist
natürlich eine riesen frage die ich
jetzt nicht beantworten kann
ich kann mir schon mal sagen es gibt
einige ein großteil ist mit sicherheit
zufrieden aber es gibt natürlich auch
immer sachen mit denen die leute
unzufrieden sind auch sachen die nicht
so gut funktionieren und vielleicht
machen wir
demnächst einfach mal eine episode
darüber interessiert dass mehr leute von
euch schreibt uns mal in die kommentare
während kaya fragt ich möchte wissen was
die deutschen über die türken in
deutschland denken ja und wie soll ich
das in einem satz beschreiben geht nicht
denn das ding als sehr komplex wie die
meisten fragen die uns stellt was kann
man dazu sagen natürlich gibt es auch
hier wieder leute die sagen werden
wir wollen keine türken in deutschland
die gibt es immer aber ich würde sagen
das ist nicht die große mehrheit in
deutschland die meisten leute leben ganz
normal zusammen
und wenn man sich leute anguckt von
meiner generation oder noch jünger da
ist das zusammenleben ziemlich normal
geworden es gibt sehr viele leute die
unmittelbar zusammen wohnen es gibt
döner das ist mittlerweile sozusagen das
deutsche nationalgericht kann man sagen
und das sind auch all die positiven
seiten vom zusammenleben man nimmt sich
das beste aus jeder kultur und macht was
gutes daraus was sehr interessant ist
dass es mittlerweile auch viele leute
aus zweiter oder dritter generation gibt
die vielleicht türkische eltern haben
den türkischen namen haben
aber deutsche sind und die immer so ein
bisschen grat wandern zwischen beiden
kulturen die vielleicht in deutschland
nicht hundertprozentig deutsch sind in
der türkei aber nicht hundertprozentig
türkisch sind und das kann natürlich vor
und nachteile mit sich bringen ich denke
wir werden da demnächst mal auch mal ein
video zu machen denn es ist unheimlich
spannend zu sehen wie das zusammenleben
funktioniert was ist alles gutes gibt
was dadurch entstanden ist und auch wie
sich die leute fühlen die beide kulturen
kennen und zwischen beiden kulturen hin
und her wandern
hier kommt ein kommentar aus südafrika
oder namibia weiß es nicht keiner reb
schreibt uns ich habe eine kurze frage
jetzt wird es ernst warum ist deutsch so
geil
das weiß ich auch nicht
karl sagt ich lerne deutsch nur weil es
nahe an meiner mutter sprache afrikaans
ist und so viele worte gleich sind diese
videos freue mich sehr und haben wir
auch gigantisch geholfen diese spannende
sprache zu lernen ja brandet kaputt ist
sagt man glaube ich nur 100 oder grüße
nach südafrika oder nach namibia
streites mal wo du herkommst ich war
schon in beiden ländern und das sind
beide länder ganze den schönsten ländern
der welt und ich freue mich sehr dass
wir jemanden haben von soweit im
südlichen afrika der unsere sündenbocks
viele grüße an dich und letzte frage für
heute kommt von sam nun es beschreibt
vielleicht kannst du eine episode über
das wort schon machen was sind alles die
bedeutung und in welchem kontext
benutzern ist generell heißt schon im
englischen already oder jetzt beispiel
hast du schon den müll rausgebracht
warst du gestern schon einkaufen oder
erst heute
das ist so die standard bedeutung
darüber hinaus gibt es viele sätze also
redewendungen in denen schon eine
bedeutung spielt und wo ist dann eine
leicht andere bedeutung gibt hier
schicke ich dir meine liste die stelle
ich unten in
die kommentare beziehungsweise in die
infobox rein da kannst du mal sehen was
es noch für bedeutung gibt und dann gibt
es noch eine andere bedeutung die ist so
etwas wie eine bestätigung
zum beispiel wenn du etwas dummes
gemacht hat kann ich sagen das war schon
dumm
in diesem zusammenhang heißt schon nicht
die sondern es heißt so etwas wie
tatsächlich man kann das dann so
übersetzen das war tatsächlich dumm
hört sich aber komisch an dann sage ich
einfach das ist ganz schön dumm was du
da gemacht hat oder was du da gesagt
hast also diese beiden sind die haupt
bedeutung einmal already und einmal
tatsächlich als bestätigung ja leute das
war's schon für diese woche ich kann gar
nicht aufhören fragen zum lesen und zu
beantworten ich freue mich auf eure
fragen
ich freue mich wenn ihr uns mehr davon
schickt bitte in die kommentare und
nächste woche werden wir sie wieder
beantworten danke fürs zuschauen und bis
bald